Let's say I want to drive from Vox's
New York office to our office in DC.
That produces about
112 kilograms of CO2.
But in an electric vehicle or EV
that same drive produces
zero emissions.
It's all thanks to this
rechargeable battery
a lithium ion battery that
powers the car's electric motor.
If all road vehicles were electric
we'd be able to wipe out about
18% of all CO2 emissions
the most prominent greenhouse gas
driving climate change.
But producing these powerful batteries
can do real environmental damage.
Nickel, the key ingredient
in EV batteries
has to be mined and smelted
in a process that contaminates
waterways
drives deforestation and
pollutes the air.
And there's no better place to see this
than outside nickel processing plants
in Indonesia
next to where people
like Asvina live.
These particles are finer
than beach sand
and are harmful when inhaled.
The same nickel paving the way
for a green future
is causing life threatening problems
for the people who live near
its production centers.
But it shouldn't be this way
because Indonesia is sitting on
one of the biggest sources
of clean energy in the world.
An energy source that could help
clean up the dirty
and often hidden side of
green energy.
Indonesia has the world's largest
proven nickel reserves.
Most of them are found here.
So is a large concentration of the country's
nickel processing plants.
A lot of this nickel supplies the steel industry,
but most of the growth
the industry has seen in recent years is
driven by the demand for EV batteries.
Demand that's predicted to skyrocket.
To extrack the nickel
the rocks have to be smelted
at really high heats.
And that energy is almost exclusively provided by
coal fired plants that spew greenhouse gases
and pollute the air.
Asvina's story isn't an isolated incident.
Records of medical visits
in her area show that
respiratory infections are by far
the most common health issue.
Data from 2017 and 2018
suggests respiratory diseases are
increasing in the region
at a much faster rate
than other ailments.
But the government has yet
to release the latest data.
For Asvina, who has lived in the area
since she was a child
there's no doubt things are worsening.
Nickel is essential for a green future
but using coal fired plants
isn't actually necessary
especially in Indonesia.
Indonesia sits along the Pacific Ocean's
Ring of Fire
a stretch of hundreds of active volcanoes
that sit on top of pools of hot magma.
We only really see the immense power of this heat
when it pierces through the earth's surface.
But when it's close to the surface
that magma also heats the water
trapped beneath the earth.
That hot water can provide
That hot water can provide a continuous
and renewable flow of energy
called geothermal energy.
To capture that energy
we need to drill down to reach
underground water.
Then hot water or steam rise up to a well.
In a power plant, that hot water is often used
to heat a different liquid
that is then vaporized and used to turn a turbine
to generate electricity.
Meanwhile, the clean water extracted is funneled
back into the ground where the earth's magma
heats it once again.
And that fluid is recycled.
So there are no emissions of any gases
to the atmosphere.
In that sense, it's a completely green
carbon-free energy source.
Plus, it doesn't rely on the weather
like wind or solar energy do.
Indonesia is the second largest
geothermal producer in the world.
On the same island where coal-fired plants
are powering nickel production
there's a plant tapping into
geothermal power.
There are about 20 active
geothermal plants.
There are also tens of sites
explored for development.
One of the biggest things holding
geothermal back in Indonesia
and other parts of the world
is cost.
And then once you've got evidence that there's a resource
the idea is then to figure out
how big is the resource
how hot is the resource
and how much would it cost to
develop that type of resource?
Longer timeline, higher risk factor
and higher initial investment costs
are all things that make geothermal
more challenging to put online.
And while geothermal maps like this one
can help identify possible hotspots...
you never know what you're going to find
until you actually drill.
Over time, the hope is that
geothermal exploration will become cheaper,
more predictable
and so efficient that it'll bring the cost down.
But it can be tough to change
an existing industry,
especially if there's a lot of money in it.
Encouraged by Indonesia's
push to attract foreign investment
and deregulation of environmental
protections
Chinese companies have
invested or committed
about $30 billion to nickel plants
in Indonesia, particularly in Morawali
where new coal fired plants like this one
being built to power
the investment.
For people like Asvina
the fact that geothermal doesn't produce
emissions or air pollution
could make it the solution
they're looking for.
Because if nothing changes
they might have to
leave their homes.
Today, geothermal plants are mostly
confined to volcanic areas
but our EV batteries are made of
metals and minerals
from around the world.
And about 60% of the energy
we used to process them
comes from fossil fuels.
There's enormous potential for cleaner
EV battery production
in all these yellow and red regions
if we dig deeper
and find ways to tap into the underground heat
whether there's underground water or not.
Like every new resource,
the work we do  to harness it
requires careful consideration.
How do you preserve parklands
and how does that coexist with
geothermal development?
The other issue that seems
to come up a lot
when I read about geothermal is
seismic activity.
Most of the geothermal induced seismicity
that occurs is very low level seismicity
but the goal is to not have significant seismicity
that could cause damage
and distress to local communities.
The challenges are to making these
environmentally, socially,
and economically viable.
And that's a very important challenge
especially if we think of
geothermal as a solution
to clean up the supply chain
that powers our clean energy.
Because all too often
it's poor and marginalized communities
who live next to power plants
smelters, mines, factories,
pipelines, waste plants.
As we move towards a better future
it's important to make sure
it isn't just green but fair.